i think olivia is so brave
um i think
people don't know her they know what she
what happened to her and i think she's
coming to dancing with the stars to be
able to tell her story and show her
vulnerability dancing with the stars
season 30
it is happening how did you feel i mean
look obviously last season was your
first season
but you had to know okay if you do
another one season 30 is right around
the corner did you have ideas in your
head about what you would want to do
from some time ago of course
[Music]
you're like i always have a plan of
course i was like i already knew what
the first outfit was going to be walking
out for season 30.
what can you tease for us
season 30
think just think of 30.
oh and my outfit
tyra i know
you the thing is you never fail to
surprise us so i would fully believe
that you'd do something like 30 outfit
changes in one episode or something no
but we're actually thinking of doing 30
it's not super
like
locked but maybe i should just lock it
with you right now with e.t to say
season 30 of dancing with the stars i'm
gonna do 30 outfit changes in 11 weeks
11 episodes
i know on live tv you're you're okay i'm
saying it we've discussed it with the
stylist and what we okay it's happening
i don't know how we're gonna do that
though
that's almost three changes per
episode tyra you're promising me this
yeah oh my gosh
he didn't mean to make you do that but
we're happy to see it well uh this i i
want to ask you about the cast because
it's the season 30 cast olivia jade you
know i i look at the instagram comments
when the cast was announced i think she
got the most backlash her name did you
were saying she's not a star she doesn't
deserve to be there what would you say
to those people who came for her and
what can we expect from her story on the
show
you know
i think olivia's so brave
um i think
people don't know her
they know what she what happened to her
um
she has said that she did not know about
what was going on
and it's really sad and it's it's very
hurtful when
something publicly happens but you had
nothing to do with and you didn't know
so i trust that she said she didn't know
she didn't know putting yourself out
there is scary and i know this audience
is obviously very large there's a lot of
people that tune in so
i hope i'm well received and people like
me but
we'll see just taking it day by day and
i think she's coming to dancing with the
stars to be able to tell her story and
show her vulnerability and
is she a celebrity
not traditionally but what is celebrity
today
if that's the case then there's no
instagram um you know influencer that is
a celebrity like it is we are in a whole
different world and celebrity has taken
a turn and a change
um and if people are talking about you
you're famous
i don't know if you remember this but
remember when there was that housewives
rumor hubbub that you weren't allowing
housewives on the cast yes and i had
asked you about it and you said
absolutely not true i'm not a part of
casting this is a this is a very uh
let me be real with you
it is a very
sadly orchestrated nastiness
yeah i'm gonna be real
um that is it needs to be said
um i have nothing to do with casting um
but there are some people that love to
start nasty rumors and i know who they
are and i look at them but i know who
they are
um and it's sad and it is what it is um
but one thing i'm like i'm so excited
about is that
one of my best friends
from 20 years ago kenya moore is on the
show she's a housewife
we've like her being on the show has
made us reconnect i love her so much
we were so so close like close to my
family spend the night in my house like
and so for her to be there i have to be
very careful not to play favorites
because she is like family and i think
dancing with the stars brought us
together again and i had nothing to do
with casting her because i don't i don't
cast a show
um and so they kind of said kenny
moore's i was like are you serious and i
emailed her she has the same email from
20 years ago
um so
aol
uh actually yes or one of those hotmail
or something um and um i um
i'm she's like my sister so it's very
special brian austin green the rumor is
not confirmed but the rumor is he's
going to be dancing with his real-life
girlfriend partnered with her sharna can
you tell us if that's true and if so
what do you think it would mean for
their relationship
um i cannot tell you if that is true or
false but i do think that if they were
dancing together that would be so
amazing right
like you know because there's so many
different types of dance um there's like
the sexy dance there's the like i'm mad
at you dance and you're like wait did
you guys have a fight last night or is
that like part of the stance we're gonna
watch some therapy okay yeah yeah i
think so i think it's gonna be very
special if they dance together
um
matt james we have had two back-to-back
bachelor nation alumni win the show
what do you think him being cast will
mean sometimes the pros are like these
bachelor people we can't beat the fandom
like what will matt james being on the
show mean competitively for everyone
well first of all matt james is a first
right he's the first black bachelor so
already that's like amazing you know and
so now he's gonna be the first black
bachelor uh dancing with the stars
um i don't know can you dance back i
don't know you fine you look good but
can't you dance some people have
questioned his dancing ability after
seeing his tick tocks which are very
cute oh really but maybe he's maybe he's
like just trying to be you know on
purpose kind of i don't know but i have
to do people beat
do do the competitors have a fair chance
when bachelor nation is so strong
they have to dance better
my mother used to say that to me it's
almost like
okay i'm gonna compare so when i was a
model and my mom was like you're a black
model and you have to be better
you have to walk better you gotta pose
better you gotta you gotta like promote
yourself better you have to be better so
everybody that's not on the bachelor you
gotta be better we also got to ask
one-third we did our math right
one-third of these celebrity contestants
this season do have a professional dance
background of some kind
what will that mean for the competition
and people always say that's not fair
what do you say to them
um i've seen people that have some type
of professional dance something
and it doesn't necessarily mean that it
correlates with
ballroom dance
or latin dance it's not the same
so you may have a gymnast type of dance
or a ballet or a hip-hop or whatever
but it is there is a whole different way
of even holding your body
when you are doing ballroom dance and
you have to unlearn so many different
things so sometimes it can actually be
helpful that you have a dance background
and sometimes it can be harmful because
you have to unlearn one of those
professional dancers the incredible jojo
siwa who is breaking ground being the
first person ever to dance with the same
sex partner what did you think when you
heard that news and how do you feel like
it's gonna play out this season um we've
been talking about this even last season
of that being something that could be
very interesting and i've had so many
people reach out to me
personally in the entertainment industry
outside of the entertainment industry
tyra you're an advocate for lgbtq like
what's going on like when's it gonna
happen
and so i'm really happy to see that it
is happening this year i'm so proud of
her i told her she's not just changing
lives she's gonna save lives last season
being your first season and this is it's
a huge live show what did you walk away
with from last season
that you were like you kind of had in
your mind as you headed into this one
for yourself
more sneakers under my dresses
those high heels honey they may look
cute but they feel like crap especially
during quarantine when we're sitting in
the house in our flat feet with bare
feet and then you put on hills after
being bare feet for a year and then your
achilles tendon is hurting because it's
not used to being then your calves are a
mess
so
more flats okay um and a bit more
transparency so like telling the
audience at home what's happening
because i have a thing in my ear the
whole time and there's crazy crap
happening all the time i think i'm gonna
be a little bit more transparent with
the audience like there's a crazy
problem
a little bit more transparent once i ran
on the stage and uh because i changed
clothes during the show i remember and i
ran on the stage and i wasn't zipped up
and
i'm a television producer and a host i
know that you should be transparent and
tell the audience but everything's going
so fast i didn't say i'm not posing i'm
holding up my clothes and if i take my
arm down my outfit is going to fall off
and up next with the pasta dough blade
is
we do have to ask
you mention the quarantine will we get a
live audience this season
no
no
how do you feel about it i want the team
to be as safe as possible i want
everybody to be as safe as possible and
i think right now we're in a phase where
we haven't crossed over enough or i feel
confident as an executive producer to um
have an audience but the one thing that
i will say is with the addition of all
the lights and the spectacle it actually
looks like a bigger show it looks more
like whoa
so it's like a trade-off you don't get
the live audience but you get a stage
that looks spectacular
[Music]
you